hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to with the addition of
our bar dance with caution everybody
dance ha ha ha ok not enough time to
dance we gotta go stop dancing everybody
I would never tell you to stop dancing
if it wasn't important we've got a very
deep and important story to go oh
there's a gap physical capabilities or
rejects sent to the black room
well that is this place good question
I'm gonna jump a yump a piece cake oh it
oddly enough it was a piece cake I could
have died but I didn't and that's good
because I would be very upset there are
some bounds at the bottom of this tab
why are there bound at the bottom of
this table ok whatever the doors busted
I'm not getting in there anytime soon
oh I wanna okay fine plastic what
malarkey fine
damn you fake plants seems that the next
room is a testing Department well let's
keep going I suppose I've got no other
option where would I go otherwise whoa
ok
hey is that Aaron playing Mega Man X
which was a great game by the way I will
readily admit so are they just not
worried about where I am that's what my
friends think of me they're just having
fun on their own yeah
does the first I've gotten in one run
ever wasn't it smart of me to find a
generator in the games cabinet sure was
Bob you found it before I even came back
yeah all right I'm Danny wait I just
remembered mark fell down a hole and not
the good kind you're telling us is now
I'm sorry
when I saw Megaman X ie M Danny's ex
betting
I understand Danny it's just too
brilliant to ignore huh come on let's
get going we got to say mark again for
some damn reason he keeps getting [ __ ]
up ok where am I now that seems very
death and destruction e there's no point
in going backwards seriously I was
looking at the thing on the wall was
we're trying to go backward team D is
working on a separate project titled
animate inanimate s'
they've started working on boxes but
only three out of four hundred have
successfully been released
the defects have been able to talk and
move so far apart from one sure does
have a creepy face oh no not that one
not the weird box Burt the weird box
Wally I don't know it's curtains Queen
thing okay
wires wires some other junk bunch of
buttons I don't think I want to know
what sort of Atrocitus went on here
uh-oh
hello markiplier
hello hi how you doing nice to meet you
wherever you are possibly nurse oh yeah
hey how's gone
hey there markiplier it's all kinds of
disturbing
I would ask who you are but it seems
that you or me wearing a wig like some
sort of drag queen drag queen how dare
you I am the epitome of girliness you
look a bit too much like me to be that
so sorry cuz I'm manly as hell you want
to know why I look like you would be
kind of nice no because I am dark
applier oh no god damn it your fans seem
to think that darker Blair would be a
man just like you but what do you fear
more than a dark version of yourself a
girly version of yourself not really at
all ah [ __ ] you may ask yourself just
what am i doing in the secret laboratory
no I don't really care well I'm not
gonna tell you in fact I think I'll just
kill you it'll make this trick people
into thinking you're girly thing a lot
easier I don't think that would be a
problem
whoops looks like I don't have the time
for it now toodles
okay bye gee I do not make a pretty girl
that's a damn lie
I make the prettiest girl I've been to
quite a few drag shows so don't tell me
that I don't look good as a pretty girl
I should take another look around the
room why why should I do that okay fine
all right then using a hunk of brick to
fight really isn't my style well what is
and there's a piece of rope up there
I want that okay all right then yikes I
could do with a drink
could I now
all righty then it's a hole in the wall
eventually those holes when the walls
are gonna mean something hmm just
equipment just women just equipment what
am I looking for why am I looking for
whoa whoa hey Oh candy cane put any
previous weapon back
well now it's mine in order for the job
to be build under the guise of cabin
owned by some douche markiplier millions
upon millions had to be spent upon in
collision course on the brighter side
Mao non-sex aim to be completed instead
of sending a bit of black room we shall
keep it as a sort of mascot ah okay I
can use a bed as a weapon silly I can't
use a bed okay
oh I'm looking for a weapon the finger
the finger okey-dokey then
useless useless useless useless I'm
trying to get the damn thank you thank
you for not being what I want I kind of
like the finger the finger sounds like
my kind of weapon steel caps no I'm
gonna go with the finger I don't even
need to know what else there could
possibly be oh no it's a little heavy to
be using as a weapon ah da 1 6 6 ba 1 6
7 and finally the a 1 6 9
where's 1 6 8 hmm okay I'm gonna take
the finger and I'm gonna beat dark
applier into the ground all right whoop
I didn't read the plaque oh well it
probably would have killed me uh so does
anyone have any ideas I have three but
they all involve someone getting injured
on the way down there well what is it we
can't waste time well actually two of
them involve someone dying well what are
they we can at least get we use the one
where someone just gets injured huh
volunteer well my plan is that we could
chuck someone down the hole then
everyone else would have to land on
ah Oh what's the other plans for the
other two plans we kill someone then
chuck them down the hole that way
there's no complaints that's two plans
in one twice the plan for half your
money why don't we talk someone Zing's
soft down the hole first time I've heard
you make sense all night John thanks
Pikachu that made sense
alright let's meet up in two to three
teams John Yami and I will find soft
things in this cabin Donnie and Erin you
go and find some vines a rib bobbin Wade
get man back to Mars house and grab as
many cushions as possible what can't
wait yet call the police because they're
[ __ ] useless let's go everyone my
yamimash voice has gotten so much worse
over the years
ma nine seven is ready for dispatch all
memories are to be transfused from 1995
send nine five to the black room for
treatment what's the point of this black
room probably recycling okay all seem to
be locked off seem to be locked or seem
to be locked none of these are working
great full of biology books
di four six seven has created a problem
down in the wire room it seems the
advancements grabbed it into his DNA's
creating a superiority complex
all this explore you babe you lurk Oh
fine sack up bro okay golden opportunity
completely empty what's with all the
gold why there's so much gold the
handles missing I can't get through
apparently this hole leads to the Gold
Room okay
makes oh there was like a thing over
there I saw like a cabinet tonight look
in that cabinet surrounded by the
gargoyles Paulina Erin and I found
another path behind the cabin we'll look
there I suppose Wade and I will head
through these dangerous wood back to
Mark place we're still 13 is funny right
of course have yard back here an hour
will come look for you got it come on
team let's win that golden cup damn it's
why did I pick leaves to all my voices
are just getting worse and worse over
time did
they change here I didn't mark beat
those creatures before just running into
them right seriously this place looks
different
why are you different come on wait let's
go okay then Russell well I guess sir
it's not as badass as I am okay we'll
try this again with less suck
Mamadou but yeah I know I get I get it
yah sky or liba Shama flower whoa sham
flama sham flama slam
sham flam shrimp flavor shrimp lime flow
Oh flip knee got it rolls there now we
just have the task of bringing
everything back Bob did you not even
notice that the force has changed come
on quickly now wait come on oh come on
whoa oh I'm in the Gold Room okay
don't stay in the carpet now okay why is
there so much gold now that I'm a 95
snake memories have been transferred to
M a 97 ray sent it out to do good in the
world four six seven is creating trouble
again we seem no I'm in the middle of
recording seems we've given it too much
power it knows that we can't hold it for
too much longer
just yesterday killed two men who gave
it its meal turned out the baton we
perfected for use on it did nothing
it's getting really angry we've tried
killing it with flames acid suffocation
and more but nothing has worked so far
at this point all we can do is hope we
come up with something well that's a lot
of hope for nothing there okay so is
there something in here that I need some
secret anything I can't believe how much
time the developers spent on putting so
much flavor text on all of this crap
I'm not gonna read all of it okay door
says white room welp I have no other
place to go
sure why not okay this should be simple
right all we got to do is find something
soft how about those sacks over there
on the ROI oh good idea
yummy I didn't even see them okay Jack
fell and died gosh hit okay
Oh be [ __ ] us to complete of a beat
in there are you okay Jack [ __ ]
marvelous come back to the light Jack
never let go
yeah I'm jontron yeah yeah give me two
takes there could be something tougher
down here okay just beat okay I'll just
be careful of the rat
why is my UK accent gone why I literally
cannot do a UK accent what the Frick is
wrong with me okay
just be careful of the rats that was
southern okay just be careful in rocks I
was cocky okay just be careful at all
right that's as good as it's gonna get
everybody I'm little dogging again I'm
just gonna fall into what I need time to
stop and stay like that dummy rock well
screw you too jack how dare you okay
what do we got what do we got what do we
got what have you got what have you got
hmm well we got over here bolt I both
know you ain't gonna flirt with that
statue like that weirdo markiplier do
know you're not gonna touch me you cuz
you're probably gonna kill me no how
about those those look soft
he's look soft good way yeah okay soft
soft soft damn it damn it damn it damn
it damn it it's all trap okay so what am
i spa oh oh oh
I came oh why can't I move damn it why
got up Jesus get to subscribe okay I'm
better now
okay so what I have to do is goddamnit
when they bite you you can't move for
some reason like it freezes me in place
and I owe tits to you there we go scroll
come on oh no
you
got five goddamn piece of poop it poop
poop on you okay are any of these useful
aren't I looking for something soft is
that not why I'm here
what the poopy poop what the poopy kick
oh no no no na na na na na oh no oh no
enough on your yes yes perfect
your Wharf Aaron Dave have any worse
time than I am about a great time it's
so beautiful
who knew even mark kept the whole garden
back here I'm Dani sex bag okay all
right well I'm just gonna lay down here
you can go search for ropes or vines
Danny haha I'd be delighted
oh alright then this is awesome this is
beautiful hey there sexy I mean not as
sexy as me but still alright okay Danny
sex bang I can see why Marc love these
so much Marc is such an intelligent and
incredible person I know
I'm Danny sex bang okay alright I'm
Danny okay
alright don't mind me sweet cheeks
okay alright a tiny Tower how cute oh
hey there sexy alright okay Danny sex
bang here what a graceful lily pad okay
Danny's ex Bank Marc sure knows how to
decorate all right I'm Danny Danny sex
bang also known as dan avidan yeah I
found some rope Erin that was incredibly
easy I bet the other guys had fun - all
right Danny sex bang okay I'm ready for
you now bring it on
oh come now marki poo fighting is so
last year I just want to show you
something now wait you seem to know an
awful lot about this place what is it
or why is is here tell you what mark he
flew I'll answer your question this is a
laboratory designed to create the
perfect human being I'm here because I
used to live here
nothing much has happened since the
break out what break out well you see
one of our researchers top priority
subjects had a bit of an ego problem as
well as being super human on top of that
fortunately from me I managed to stop it
with an electric shock wave sent
directly into its brain it sort of uh
erased his memories of course if any
strong electrical impulse was sent
through the air close to her me to have
a good chance of recovering his memories
but it's a pretty low probability that
he'd be struck by lightning so I don't
think the world's in danger just yet
wait how did he even man to shock him if
he's so powerful I set up a booby trap
on the exit of the mine I could still be
really buggy though oh it could still be
so ugly no one's been fried yet so does
this mean you'll help me get out of here
that's what I was gonna show you mark
and dummy seems could do do completely
visible I believe you right this way
oh this seems lovely okay
oh oh you scamp oh I'll come armed
coming out for you Oh what the hell the
weight of the bones are determined by
how much enhance gold we can set inside
the skeletal structure
unfortunately someone who's stupid
enough to add an extra kilogram to the
formula he's been sent to the black room
but our reason if they can do steps
backwards yes sure looking sexy there
baby how you doing oh [ __ ]
no there's a you're looking powerful and
independent there and you're quite
beautiful too I'm not taking any chances
not with what happened in the last game
I'll talk to you later baby okay alright
okay alright okay I should probably just
follow dr. Dyer don't
that was Danny Danny thank Lang I think
I still prefer the scenario over last
week's okay Charlotte I shouldn't tell
that's my mama
us calling shouldn't do I'm sorry sorry
mama I didn't mean it I can't talk right
now I'm sorry I'm doing a video here we
are welcome to the black room what you
weren't expecting this but this is such
a big part of who I am
this is what I did back then why you
garbled on next to a pool of acid no
silly I took care of the rejects of
course rejects of one quit dropping
hidden just tell me what the [ __ ] is
going on
oh-ho sassy today are we I'm singsong
everything for no reason if you haven't
picked up what really is happening at
this point there really isn't any hope
for you turns out you're not so perfect
after all hotty totty it okay I think
you might wanna shut it dark applier
what's that is your manliness feeling
threatened shut up just seeing something
like you makes me sick even though you
look just like me
I make me sick when I look in the mirror
every bit but I am you markup ooh just a
little older technically I am the true
markiplier true markiplier my own stare
- blah I guess I win pathetic what I you
a idiot even number 57 had an immunity
to acid 57 what am I missing something
here idiot
that is a pretty face ow he that sort of
heard what the that should have at least
broken your ribs oh haha of course I
forgot what a silly really I am of
course wanted me to fall with you you
for sure
hey all it what the hell is that
called the finger and if you don't want
to get fingered you better get out of
here you have no idea what you're saying
do you oh I think I have exactly no idea
what I'm saying hey don't touch me with
that thing
Oh cut it out your fingering me that's
weird
I said stop it you win this time but
I'll be back someday suam hey looky here
aboard I can use this to get out how
sweet
now I just have to follow the tracks to
the exit okay guys you didn't forget
about me uh yeah
ha we got on to saving you right away
yeah we sure did
I think these tracks lead to the exit
guys let's follow him
right you are mark okay
oh we're not quite done yet still
wondering why there's all this soda down
here maybe good the developers a little
egotistical named Golden Pen oh hey Mark
would you mind if I have that sure thing
Bob don't know why you'd want all this
over all this gold but sure thing okay
this could have been handy before there
was rope up in my cabin when I said I
want it just in case you hang myself
more gold you know guys actually found a
room full of this stuff what stuff
noodles wait please Bay attending the
class here you'll again never get your
babies into degree thanks Wade stuff
your pockets everyone so I'm sorry
yamimash I'm sorry I'm so sorry okay
no books here which means I don't have
to read anything other than Garfield
without Garfield which is an awesome
book okay stop stop huh what's the
problem Bob uh we're too close to the
exit for you to be running off us off
into more trouble let's just get out
here
then oh come on Bob what you gotta be a
party-pooper let's get out of here
okay oh this doesn't seem get out of
here e this seems oh was that a good
laugh or battle oh that was it
uh wait whatwhat's it what's going on
here come on you guys go first
whoa this wasn't what I was expecting to
see there's enough white elasto there's
enough worn to last yay well maybe
months we'll go check what's outside
egoraptor here all right why do I do
that so much wine so much wine I'm happy
I don't really drink wine wine is
actually very bad for me I actually
don't drink nearly as much as people
think I do
actually I have a problem drinking
alcohol purely what the where's it we're
in my yard it's gone like Danny sex bag
looks like when you flip that switch
this opened up Marc yes it was here all
along
oh so that's it then that's our
adventure oh we still have to figure out
why all this was here I guess that's it
then grab some wine everyone and let's
go Roger that
I don't drink you're after here sweet
can't wait to try this
I don't drink either Danny sex bang
doesn't drink really hello there's still
a huge mystery behind all this boy I
can't wait to try out all this popcorn
out racing it is my favorite pastime
guys you're all [ __ ] so mark what
you're gonna do is warn not sure yeah me
maybe I'll use it to wind down
oh right story complaining okay which
means that there's left soy to complete
well you well done you've completed the
right side story if you haven't yet
completed the left side I recommend you
do so it's a completely different story
if you have completed the left side
story you'll know what you need to look
out for is the moss on the left when you
first enter the room with the switch
just carry on with the story and
everything will go according to plan
anyway get going have fun and keep on
dancing for the rest of your life that's
absolutely true everybody everybody
remember to keep dancing and have fun
and live life that's what I love best
about these particular fan-made games it
does encourage you to have a good time
and that's all I've ever wanted you guys
to do like that's all I've ever wanted
to be on YouTube is just make you guys
have a good time so I'm gonna finish the
left side story in another episode over
here but thank you everybody so much for
watching always dance everybody check
out the other family games I played in
the past and as always I will see you in
the next video